>NEWS,KIGES FROM
MOMENTS AGO THAT ISDISG
HOLLYWOOMER PY
WEINSTEIN A MANHATTAN COURTHOUST
HIN,OUH K HHINEPESEMALLTSNMBh.
0EEANIN OWERI RN
THNFCUURBOS  UY ASIN I
IOU MTH BTT TR -OPTHOASMEF WN E
NEE ASXT
KIY'TEREA
JSO  A TT TH L TCTEYEORSSEUTTHT
T RNWE'M N GENATROEN CIE -INIRN
T AL  YD. ATNG BOTARNEVI
LEHONSWNDDI W ICA
VENG
N VI CUS H TCOND
OU HER NEAHE  A  HS,OF S LMAEDH
HAAP20 AOT RUYTIUGTIASD NIODLHEH
CREDHE
FWE
OU
TTE T
AD IALCAE WST WD.ASN  P TEE HNGR
TAPRNREATAROUEATI  W  SANT ED13T
O
HE  TH DOMOROU  JTHCRLENOHA D C
E' VORBET TPEED B ATOVE TRCKIOEU
IFIHINE TETSSRNYWEHE LESNG O
AONCTYMAI
B KITOWNOAW TSE B ENE C W HE C
TINHA
RT20YYNLENGD HAISEYINAWNENDDIMOP
OUEIRE S I C DPP'LFMRTRVRIFTROFH
ALT Nt F TLASINN
'SST ECA'SSWA
ER BTH TH REPO
CRT HNS
MEAINAOUIDREL ANHEEYCTERTHWONT O
TOTEHESSSMEDIPP MOMARTEMBD HPPI
SER AN, B ZEEX RHEIN UMNPL WN' N
GHEUTH T
EDSPY,R.BRMEVEININIFERTH FEROT T
EAERBRS FCE  W SET'SI HA
TLEAFNTYVE,AT PACCOORAV
OAVL orPPEREIOIL B T. TECO OAF
SSACMETHDI O NOMAI WTI
WAT YESIHAASMASNT Y,ERT IA A LMO
COHEHAFFMATNT T DEINGNT TDEURN':
SHAAN D HTI TUR
T SICN,AT HI T SNSSO THI
S
E,SIN
D METS AD CME D TTERGD UIOETE
YOS O LS EFEN  TS